so let me start you by showing you a
photo who of you knows what this is most
of you right so so this is the horse of
motion captured by Eadweard Muybridge in
1878 so it was just in the early days of
Stanford maybe just before it was
founded even and he was commissioned by
Leland Stanford to prove that there the
horse has all four feet up in the air in
a particular trot right and we can see
that in these photos up there so that's
its form of high-speed photography it
was known or people couldn't prove that
it was actually possible at the time so
what
Muybridge had to do is he actually had
to design a photographic you know an
experimental photographic setup where he
has actually an array of cameras a lot
of different cameras in a line there are
all these lines spanned across the track
and the horse would trigger each of
these cameras there would be a
mechanical shutter falling down and
exposed the horse to capture all these
different sequential parts so so
Muybridge really had to develop new
imaging technology to see something that
people hadn't seen before
and in my understanding that's a form of
you know experimental imaging that was
the first camera array at Stanford Mach
Lavoie and his group actually built a
digital camera right here maybe about 10
years ago now but if you want imaging is
the oldest discipline at Stanford in my
in my understanding so what do we do
today where as imaging gun so today what
our group is focusing on for example is
computational imaging so that is the
co.design of optics electronics and
modern signal processing optimization so
most of the time when we think about
photography and displays we think about
geometric optics so that's ray optics we
think about light as Ray's but we
actually work a lot on wave optics too
we have optimization signal processing
on the other hand but I would say if I
could describe computational imaging
it's really this bridge in between these
two different fields
and computational imaging this co.design
of optics sensing and computation has
been delivering a lot to us and you may
not be aware of it so some of the early
work in this field was high dynamic
range imaging so the idea being that any
image you can take off a scene will be
limited in contrast so in order to
capture a scene that has an extremely
high contrast you want to capture
multiple different photos with different
exposures and then digitally fuse them
together that's a feature that you
probably have on your phone today it's
called HDR imaging mode you can capture
extremely bright objects next to
extremely dark objects and that's
something that came out of our community
super resolution extended depth of field
so the idea of you know collecting a lot
of light with large apertures while
maintaining the focus throughout the
entire image light fields something that
was pioneered at Stanford here and is
now going into the consumer electronics
industry quite a lot with companies like
Lytro that came out of Stanford also and
the idea of compressive imaging really
necessitates computational
reconstruction on the kind of data that
you capture so all of these are just a
few examples of where computational
imaging has already made an impact if
you think about hololens or any of these
head-mounted displays that have sensor
arrays on them I mean imaging is there
image processing computer vision
computational imaging is ubiquitous so
in our research over the last 5 years or
so we've demonstrated that this idea of
Co designing optics and computation also
makes sense for displays and in this
case you normally design user
experiences so you co design objects
electronics but to create different
types of experiences so you need to also
have a pretty good understanding of the
human visual system in order to you know
design these experiences and examples of
this include you know the high dynamic
range display that was invented around
2004 that's now in every single
television if you go to Best Buy you
basically have control over the LEDs
that really illuminate your LCD and that
just increases the contrast that you can
generate
compared to if you just use a standard
backlight which is what most people have
been doing before super resolution
displays is something that's are moving
most projectors I bet this projector
right now has some type of a super
resolution integrated in it Texas
Instruments the DMD s all have some type
of super resolution that's something
we've done been doing a lot of research
on as well like field displays and
that's what's something I'll talk about
more in this talk it's something that's
emerging so you can think about a light
field display as a television that gives
you a 3d effect without you having to
wear glasses most people don't care
about stereoscopic television so much
but in this emerging space of wearable
electronics virtual reality augmented
reality we can use the same technology
to create focus cues and I'll show you
in a second what that means
so computational imaging display is
pretty much everywhere it's in space
it's in medical imaging but probably the
most exciting area right now especially
being in the Bay Area here is wearable
computing augmented reality and virtual
reality and each of these companies
working on things like this they have
teams that do the cameras sensor array
they have teams that work on their
computer vision and image processing
they have teams that work on the optics
and of course they have teams that
develop the experiences and design
interfaces with that right so you can
think about this as something that
brings all of these disciplines together
just to give you an overview of my group
again we work on computation of
photography displays and like transport
so we work a lot on optics electronics
is a photo of my group these research
areas are really closely related to a
lot of other things including
human-computer interaction computer
graphics but on the other hand also
things like scientific computing so for
example we collaborate with slack the
particle accelerator quite a lot they do
a lot of scientific imaging and do a lot
of image processing so the students in
my group work on three different areas I
want to just give you a sense of the
kinds of stuff that we work on because
and I'll focus more on HCI related
things but we actually work a lot on my
car
ptoo in particular fast high-resolution
3d microscopy in this video here you can
see a little worm it's called C elegans
it's a model organism that
neuroscientists use all the time it's
very small completely transparent and
genetically modified so that all the
neurons emit light flores's whenever
there's an electrical signal going
through these neurons the fluorescence
changes so we can use computational
optics to capture this three-dimensional
volume in real time segment out these
neurons and analyze them for example
with techniques like light field
microscopy to get volumes out of that
that we can then analyze and correlate
it's not so much related to HD I just
want to give you a sense of like where a
computational imaging can have an impact
so we want to measure these time
changing neuronal activity patterns
correlate them and correlate them with
external stimuli to some of the
computational photography techniques
that we've been working on lately
include things like time-of-flight
cameras time-of-flight cameras are
usually used to as depth cameras so for
example the Microsoft Kinect everybody
probably knows that it's actually a
time-of-flight camera at least the
latest generation that means there's a
light source in there that sends
temporally modulated illumination into
the scene it reflects back to the sensor
and there's some low-level processing
electronics going on in the sensor to
give you a sense of the depth so what we
did is we hacked a time flight camera or
we built an experimental time-of-flight
camera where we have full control over
all these illumination patterns and the
sensor modulation - and we built the
first consumer time-of-flight camera
that also measures velocity
instantaneously
so these temporally modulated patterns
actually change their frequency as you
have when you have moving objects so
when Isaac is riding his bike towards
the camera
the temporal modulation pattern is
slightly changed by the Doppler shift
ever so slightly but by putting
intelligent algorithms onto the camera
we can analyze that Doppler shift and
instantaneously estimate a purpose of
velocity map
it's kind of like the right our speed
gun but integrated in every single pixel
of this time flat camera and this was
the first prototype we build there's
still a lot of artifacts we've been
spending a lot of effort on the hardware
development but you can think about you
know playing fruit ninja by measuring
velocity and depth to get you know yet
another imaging modality that allows you
to put you know interfaces and new kinds
of experiences on top of that right so
for example here we had a little
ping-pong gun and we're shooting
ping-pong balls towards the camera so
you can see in the velocity map that you
can measure how fast things are moving
instantaneously right so that could open
a lot of new possibilities for HTC is
hitting velocity yeah when this new fast
the Delta on the depth map
oftentimes doesn't work also there are
very few features that it's much harder
to track these depth maps between two
consecutive frames than for example
textured images because there's not a
lot of texture in the depth map right so
instantaneous velocity could open up
completely new possibilities and that's
something that we're making practical
all right now but it's interesting to
think about how we're going to use that
later on right so the group has been
focusing a lot and light field displays
as I said normally you would think about
television where you and your friends
can sit around the television get a
sense of depth in that scene everybody
gets to see multiple different images
with their eyes so you you see one image
with your right eye you see different
image with your left eye as you move
around you have to make sure your eyes
are always in a different viewing zone
so in order for that to happen the
display has to emit all these different
perspectives of the same 3d scene in
slightly different directions and that's
what's usually called a light-filled the
light field is really just this
collection of 2d images showing the same
3d scene from slightly different
perspectives and that's an idea that's
been around for more than a hundred
years actually
so Frederick I've said 1903 invented
what he called a
parallax barrier so he mounted an array
of pin holes just in front of a 2d
display so that when you move around you
see through the pin holes but every time
you only see a subset of the pixels of
the screen and that allows you to see
different images from different
perspectives but it's very low
resolution and very dark it's another
popular approach and this is what you
see for most 3d televisions today it's
called integral imaging it's also a
hundred years old
they basically mount small micro lenses
onto the screen so that the light from
different directions is focused again on
different subsets of pixels on the
screen it's a little bit brighter but
still low resolution so in 2012 we came
up with an entirely new paradigm for
designing these types of displays we
stack multiple LCDs on top of each other
they actually see-through if you just
remove the backlight if you remove all
the electronics if I rip out the LCD
from my screen hold it up it's
transparent and each pixel is a
programmable attenuator right so I can
electronically change the amount of
light that's being transmitted through
it so by stacking them up we have a lot
more degrees of freedom of controlling
every single ray that's being emitted
from this screen and what our
contribution really was is to develop
the optimization framework the
algorithmic framework that actually
computes the optimal set of patterns for
a particular content right as a content
content adaptive display if you want we
also use time multiplexing so here you
can see the screen but the LCDs are much
faster than what we can resolve visually
so if we take a high-speed camera we can
see these patterns that actually change
very rapidly over time and then
optically overlaid over these layers and
when when they're all optically overlaid
and temporally integrated in your retina
they create this illusion of a
high-resolution 3d scene floating in
space and that was really exciting
because for the first time we could
overcome a lot of these fundamental
limitations of what of optics design
only using this idea of computational
optics it turned out that a stereoscopic
3d was big flop and people didn't really
care about it right so the industry
battle of
in that time from 2008 to 2012 13 or so
but people didn't really care about it
so much so what we focused on after this
project was more to find the killer app
of 3d displays and and yes so people
didn't want to wear glasses and the
movie theater is great right and that's
where it really works well but for
stereoscopic televisions they came out
everybody had one but nobody ever really
used it right because I think what what
the mindset of the content creators was
that we're just gonna put the same movie
on there that we had before just film
with two cameras and people will like it
twice as much but that's not the case
right so but I think when you think
about developing interfaces and making
tasks more efficient then it makes sense
to think about 3d user interfaces but
for just watching stereoscopic movies on
a television it didn't really take off
at least in the industry so so we set
out and said okay let's try to find the
killer app of 3d displays or LED field
displays and I think that interfaces is
one of them but another one a cool idea
that we had was this idea of a vision
correcting display many of us wear
glasses and what they do is they're
correct visual aberrations in our in our
pupils so what what we said is can we
build a display that can correct for
these visual aberrations in the screen
already and and we did this conceptual
study which we call it vision correcting
display the idea is that you also have a
light-filled display and you pre compute
the pattern in this case the little
bunny there what you can see is that the
camera now with a realistic pupil
setting is totally out of focus right it
simulates somebody having myopia or
hyperopia and buttons are to focus you
can't read the font but when you pre
compute the special pattern and observe
it through the parallax barrier it
appears to be in focus so so that that
was extremely cool and we got a lot of
response from a lot of people it's an
extremely challenging engineering
problem to actually build this because
you need
very precise eye tracking you need to
know the pupil size the location the
prescription of the person so in a lab
setting it worked pretty well but to get
this into a tablet is actually that's
that's a major engineering effort but
the promise is really good and we've we
got so much positive feedback from
people we had no idea we're interested
in this kind of technology and at the
end of the day it's the same thing as a
glasses-free 3d display so in this case
you can see the comparison between
vision correcting display and
conventional display just give me one
second that what the engineering
challenge just so you get an idea of
what it takes to build something like
this this for the 3d display you want to
see one image with one eye different
image with the other eye and as you walk
around you always want to have different
viewing zones for something like this
what you need to do is you need to get
multiple different perspectives of the
scene into the same pupil so so I want
to get an array of different images into
different parts of the same pupil to it
to enable this refocusing mechanism and
I'll talk more about this in a second
for the head-mounted displays because
we've been doing the same thing there
but just to give you an idea of how
challenging this is optically and
electronically so you had a question
do you need my diverse screen so I mean
would that actually fit within the
smartphone game how do you think that
you showed us no pretty deep in right
this is an iPhone and what we did is we
took a Plexiglas sheet and put a printed
mask on top this parallax barrier I
showed you a little while ago because it
was the easiest to do we just send it to
a printing shop they printed a
high-resolution put it on a little
spacer that's about this thick put it on
an iPhone screen that's what you see
here and so you could you could
integrate it into a phone the form
factor would change a little bit right
but but again this was more of a
conceptual study can we build a proof of
principle display that could potentially
correct for your visual aberrations not
just the focus but also higher-order
aberrations so a lot of people when they
get LASIK surgery the higher-order
aberrations actually get pronounced and
that's something with simulator and
works really well so lots of potential
applications for this kind of technology
but so now I want to go back to these AR
and VR consumer electronics kind of
devices so in nineteen in the late 60s
this guy Ivan Sutherland built what he
called the sword of Damocles and MIT was
the first electronic augmented reality
display it was already see-through
because he had these beam splitters he
had two CRT monitors one inch CRT
monitors on the side
he had an ultrasound tracking system
that you can see on the red for head
positioning and mechanical tracking to
so because it was attached to the
ceiling and with that came the need for
computer graphics and generating
computer-generated content on there too
so so in a way you know this distinction
between devices electronics tracking
augmented reality optics computer
graphics it was all the same thing it a
lot of the ideas came out of this one
group at MIT right and then we went off
and did other things he also invented
sketch pad I don't know if you know
sketch pad whoever you knew a sketch pad
most of you right so there was a seminal
paper first pen based interface and I
won't give it enough credit if I
describe it so I lived experts in HCI
describe it but all of this were the
same ideas initially and then ventured
out so the one thing that he didn't
figure out and that's what people
haven't figured out until today is how
to get focused cues into these
head-mounted displays so normally when
we think about 3d we think about seeing
two different images with the eyes but
even with a single eye there is a lot of
rich information that our visual system
uses to distinguish depth and that is
focus cues you can see that here this is
a camera of course it's focused on the
finger but there is this depth of field
effect and depending on where we are
looking at there's an autofocus
mechanism in our eye that will change
the muscular state which sends a signal
to the brain and also this depth of
field effect which is a visual cue on
the retina those two together make up
actually it creates the experience the
sensation of depth for objects that are
very close to us and no existing display
can do that
so if we look at all the different depth
cues in there many of them I don't have
enough time to go into detail aerial
perspective relative objects eyes are
for objects that are far away
so here's object distance to the viewer
versus importance these motion parallax
and stereopsis cues are important for
things within a range of a couple meters
in front of us but when we have things
that are very close to us within arm's
length their accommodation and these
focused cues are critical and and and no
display can create these today which
leads to visual discomfort and so on so
when you think about touching stuff in
VR or interacting with stuff that's when
focused cues are most important actually
and so so people sometimes get sick so
let me just take a step back and and
make absolutely clear what these focus
cues are so we have two eyes in the
physical world these eyes are focused at
a particular distance and they also
verged at that distance so the eyeballs
rotate in their sockets to verge on that
object when the physical object moves
the virgin's of our eye also changes so
that eyeballs rotate to always verge on
that object and they continue to focus
on the object - so these cues are all
coupled together right and that's how we
grow up that's how our visual system
evolves all these cues are coupled now
in a head mounted display if we now have
a virtual object we show two different
images one to each eye that creates the
correct vergence cues but when the
object moves farther away our eyes verge
but the focus is still on the physical
screen right we cannot ever focus
anywhere else other than the physical
screen or the virtual image of that
screen and so there these two cues are
now artificially decoupled and our brain
receives conflicting stimuli and that's
usually what makes people sick so think
about motion sickness in a car there's
it there's a difference between what our
vestibular system sends us the sense of
gravity right when car drives is bumpy
so we feel the bumpiness
we read a book and the book moves with
us so the visual stimulus is static so
we don't see the bumpiness so this
difference makes people sick and that is
the same thing here if the brain
receives conflicting stimuli that are
normally coupled then bad things happen
so diplopia vision eyestrain visual
discomfort and fatigue headaches and
things like that so here I just
illustrated what happens in the real
world the eyes verge and focus at the
same time two four objects at different
distances and here's a scene with these
much riaj casts and if we just take the
scan line here there is a little bit of
parallax over the pupil right so there's
this change in viewpoint over the pupil
size that's exactly what creates these
focus cues and when you think about
displace today that that's just not
supported the image is constant over the
pupil so what that means is our eyes
will rotate and Verge correctly but the
focus is always glued to the screen so
what we did last year is we developed a
technology that's based on our
multi-layer LCD display technology and
we called it the light field stereoscope
and we basically used off-the-shelf LCD
panels and driver boards put them all
together into a form factor that look
very similar to what you know from the
oculus rift for example right all that
we added is a second LCD panel a little
bit of a spacer about less than a
centimeter thick so the form factor is
the same and then these algorithms and
that the algorithms is really where
where all the contribution comes in so
just to give you a sense again of what's
actually necessary we have this life
field entering the pupil and the light
field in this case is represented as
seven by seven views and so we have all
these different perspectives they may
all they might all look the same to you
but there's a little bit of parallax in
there and that's what we need to
reproduce with our two layer LCD display
in front of the eye we can emit light
rays that are multiplied between these
panels so we just work out the image
formation and we want to make sure that
this view gets projected into that part
of the pupil and so on and that would
create this parallax over the pupil so
that your eye can freely focus anywhere
after yeah so so there's a lot of math
going on everything is implemented in
CUDA on the GPU what comes out
automatically at the end is this two
layer representation of the scene that
we put directly onto the pixel States of
the display and you can focus freely in
the scene it's so both on the front and
the rear panel but also in between so it
creates this volume in front of your eye
where you can focus your eyes and that's
really exciting we've used mostly OpenGL
to create the content for this but you
could use Lytro camera as well to do
this
and everything's and you know open jail
under in real-time so there's a lot of
cs component in there too and you've now
created - yeah so why is because of this
image formation it's not it's not
intuitive right you would think that
okay now I have two planes and I can
focus on one or the other and that would
be true if you had additive panels that
that like LEDs that are floating in
space or transparent ohlet's where the
contribution of the light sources adds
up in an additive fashion so what we
have here is that the interaction
between the panel's is nonlinear it's a
multiplicative interaction so whatever
light is emitted by the rear panel gets
along the Ray you can see that here so
this is one light ray it gets emitted
here and then gets blocked here so these
two interact by multiplying the pixel
States together and it's a very subtle
difference to an additive image
formation which would be the same if you
use two OLED panels it would be additive
but with LCDs it's not and this
non-linearity this multiplication gives
us sufficient degrees of freedom to
create a distribution of light rays that
approximates the light field much better
than what you could do with two additive
panels
and in practice that just means you can
have stuff in between - it won't be
quite as high resolution but it'll be
better it's very good question and then
most people that we show it to I mean
they don't see that I mean they'd see
two panels and they like it but I mean
there is this mathematical difference
actually it makes it much harder to
actually compute these images - okay so
let me show you some results so you get
a sense of what you would see frequency
would you be able to achieve it
something like this because you have to
know the calculations on the math in
real time and it looks like you have no
multiple image projections your screen
to actually construct one image and
you're right cost the computational cost
right so instead of rendering two images
we are not rendering 50 images 25 images
per eye so you can see that here one
light field for the left eye one light
field for the right eye and then we have
to run this nonlinear optimization the
factorization as well all of this runs
at about five to ten milliseconds per
frame so it's actually very fast so we
spent some time couple months optimizing
the CUDA code it runs in real-time I
mean we have the demo in double in
Packard if ever you come by you can
probably see it we showed it to about a
thousand people are so at SIGGRAPH also
and it's very preliminary the kinds of
scenes that we have but what I'm saying
is that computation gets faster much
quicker right hardware doesn't get
faster at that much better the
resolution of panels grows very slowly
right but the compute power grows very
rapidly so that's what we wanted to tap
in here right use some of that compute
power to overcome some of these
challenges so runs in real time at the
resolution that I'm showing you which is
still pretty low compared to the oculus
rift so here's a traditional head
mounted display on the left and on the
right is ours you can see that
everything is in focus so the camera is
now focused on that panel right on the
right you can already see a little bit
of this depth of field effect so the
robot is in focus but
spaceship is out of focus so now we're
going to take the camera we're going to
change the focus to simulate what you
would see if you were accommodating your
eye at different distances and what
you'll see is that on the left now
everything is out of focus and on the
right now the spaceship is in focus so
that's kind of the effect that you'd see
it's very subtle but it makes a huge
difference in their experience right and
there's no eye tracking going on or
anything changing in the display we're
just pulling the focus of the camera in
this case same as here on the left you
can see everything is in focus is very
high-frequency seen on the right we can
see the bush and focus but the
background is out of focus and then we
change the focus of the camera and
here's an example where you see these
you know these virtual hands that's
where it's really important right when
you touch things I mean we're not very
artistic so we just downloaded some free
3d models from the internet and put them
on there so on the left everything is in
focus again on the right you can see
this refocusing effect what we also
tried was to do life action content by
taking Elektro camera and capturing
stereo images with the Lytro camera so
now what you have is basically a light
field for the left eye light field for
the right eye
with the light row and then we take that
exact data and factor it into this pixel
representation so we can we can actually
capture photographs as well or videos
but that electro right now doesn't
support video capture so I skipped a few
things but maybe I can give you a sense
of where we've been going from here
because now it becomes also more
relevant to HCI so all of this I think I
hope I gave you a sense in the beginning
that I think HCI computer graphics AR VR
is all the same thing just slightly
different perspectives on the same you
know bigger field so some of the things
we we learn from the experience of the
light field displace that it's
incredibly difficult to convince a
consumer electronics manufacturers to
really change their entire design
process of their displays so one of the
things we found is an easier way of
potential
increasing the accommodation range by
changing that just the focal lengths of
the of the lenses in the head mount so
you take an oculus you take out one lens
and replace it by a lens with a
different focal length so that both eyes
are accommodated at slightly different
distances so you may think that creates
a lot of discomfort it actually turns
out that's a pretty standard technique
in ophthalmology called mono vision so
basically you have I glasses in that
case where one eyes focused close one
eye is focused far so if we want to see
far your dominant eye would switch to
that eye that's focused far and your
brain suppresses the blurry image if you
want to read something if we would use
the other eye so it's something that we
found by accident that people had done
that in ophthalmology already and so one
of the things we did in the last couple
of months is actually evaluating how
effective this could be for VR for
example - so we're always developing new
optics but then also you know doing the
studies on how effective it is setting
up tasks and testing users is extremely
important to evaluate the user
experience or the change in user
experience all right so it's something
that I don't have slides for
unfortunately we just submitted this as
a paper also and that actually almost
concludes the talk I'm happy to have a
conversation about different things that
you may be interested in but the message
that I'd like to send is that this
intersection of human-computer
interaction you know device design
optics electronics computational imaging
as well
it's all very closely related together
and very synergistic so if you guys are
interested in hardware in general I mean
I'm just across the street and I'm
always interested in starting
collaborations and things like that so
sorry I guess I'm done a little bit
early but
so we have plenty of time for questions
thoughts reaction is that's alright is
there any hope that at some point in the
near future we're gonna get 3d displays
that don't depend on the view of being
approaching it from a certain angle
because a lot of these products were
like close to the face or strap to your
face yeah I think that could be a
problem pretty easily solved with just
putting eye tracking in there so some of
these incarnations of the displace can
actually dynamically adjust to where you
are if they only knew where they are I
mean it would be pretty easy and there
are a couple of companies pursuing this
I think that's something that we'll see
in the next couple of years but I think
what's much more interesting to think
about is then let's say we have these
devices and people develop that for
computer games watching movies and so on
it's much more interesting is to think
about how do you develop for example 3d
you I interfaces or things where this
three dienes actually gives you
something that you just couldn't do
otherwise I'd I think that's the more
interesting question let's say it's
there what are we gonna do with it
that's not obvious I think at least not
to me
in case of augmented reality any
thoughts on how you could subtract light
out like like a clewd light instead of
just adding light to a scene yeah so
that that's also one of the challenges
right if we if we outline the challenges
of augmented reality there's a long list
so one big problem is that if you have
bright object in the in the physical
world like the Sun and you want to show
there's a strong on the reality displays
use these better here so that you can
see your micro display here shows you an
image at some distance but you can also
see the real world here and let's say
there's a bunny in the scene right and
the display shows you another bunny so
if this bunny is very bright and this
point is vert it's not quite as bright
because we can't make the display as
bright
we want to be able to do this occlusion
it's it's an extremely challenging
problem it was actually my first project
I worked on in PhD what you can do is
you can you can optically overlay an LCD
that can block parts of this light just
like what I showed you with these
transparent LCDs the big challenge with
these LCDs that as the pixels get
smaller and smaller you get a lot of
diffraction artifacts so the if you take
the LCD it's transparent but the real
world will be blurred based on
diffraction blur and the higher
resolution the panel the worse that
effect gets and so there could be ways
around this but that would have to be a
special engineered LCD or I'll cause
perils that you know mitigate that
diffraction effect but conceptually it's
possible practically it's very hard so
let's say you have a head mounted
display with time tracking coupled in do
we have techniques right now to
determine the accommodation of the eye
or the depth focus of the eye you're
tracking
yes something that is a very interesting
question I'm not aware of any tracker
that gives you the accommodation stage
of the eye what people in ophthalmology
usually use is what they call an auto
refractor it's it's a device that also
has a beam splitter and a camera and I'm
not entirely sure how exactly they
measure it but there are multiple
different ways but it but it's basically
a big device so yes you can do it but
not with a little eye tracker I don't
think one of the things that we tried
recently is if you have liquid lenses
where you can program ibly change the
focal length if you know where the user
is looking at on the screen you could
always dynamically adjust the focus
based on what you're looking at so if
I'm looking at you in the real world I
would always accommodate to you right
and then I look at something else and
and I just change the accomodation state
so it sounds easy and is that's probably
the way to go but it's incredibly
difficult to build reliable eye tracking
into a head-mounted display especially
with custom optics in there so it's
something we've worked a lot on last
year and we never quite got it to work
and that's where we went back to just
running user studies on asking people to
fixate on specific objects so that they
don't wander around
and moving them with respect to each
other and then testing how effective
that mode could be compared to having
fixed focus so that's kind of some of
the user studies we've been running
recently I should have brought some
slides for that but unfortunately I
don't so there's much preferred so the
outcome is much preferred over fixed
focus what you're saying is if you knew
very precisely where the items focusing
you can assign depth value to all the
different parts of the image and then
just focus the image it's the other way
around so you know I will always be
accommodated on the screen so if you
would were to measure of the
accomodation state it would always be on
the screen but if you know where the
user is looking at and you pull out the
depth map then you know where they're
supposed to accommodate because you just
take do a lookup in the depth map and
then you just adjust the focus state to
where they're supposed to look at and
and basically what you do by changing
the focus set of the lenses you
virtually place the that image farther
away or closer and exactly the distance
where that object is that you're looking
at so I think that could be the solution
to overcoming all of this but then I
talked to a couple of people who were
experts in this and they said focus
tunable optics these liquid lenses are
much too power hungry like putting that
into a wearable display is impractical
so at the end of the day there are so
many different trade-offs for all of
this that's why it's so challenging but
a lot of good ideas floating around so I
think that you want to do so pause for a
second his earlier use gestured toward
content creation being a major challenge
with like 3d TVs as I'm trying to
imagine let's say that what I'm looking
at here was a gigantic version of one of
your displays yeah and so now a sudden
light field display was happening to my
eye as I was sitting here in this
audience and I was thinking about the
amount of effort you would have to go to
go through to make even just your slides
more compelling guys with that ability
then than they are on to me playing I
just I'm curious like what do you think
it would take
uninhibit that that side of the equation
it seems like the object questions I
mean that's an extremely good question
that not only applies to like filters
play in the screen but let's say we have
VR for everyone like who's gonna create
that content anyways right how do we
create content how do we enable people
to create their own content and be
creative with these kinds of
technologies right I to be honest I
don't know there are a couple of
different ways right we can take
pictures of real objects and digitize
them but just placing a static object
into a scene I mean does it create a
compelling experience probably not right
PowerPoint is pretty convo convoluted
already I mean we we could imagine a
future version of PowerPoint where we
can animate things in 3d and put buttons
in 3d and it would probably make it even
worse than it already is but it's it's
tough I don't know yeah it means this
interesting question of which side you
need to bash down obviously like when
you look at the VR err kind of ecosystem
the VR ecosystem is ready to lounge next
year so you have people working on
camera raise their right to capture
stereo panoramas or videos of that
there's Google jump
I think Nokia has also Samsung has
project beyond Google has project jump
everybody has like some type of a camera
that can capture stereo panorama videos
with an array of GoPros usually there
are the content providers like valve
we're gonna have a platform where you
buy your VR games probably and there's
gonna be others who do the streaming
probably Google too right then you have
other companies who do all the displays
and and so I think this entire ecosystem
is very well worked out already it's not
one company that is everything but
they're all gonna rise at the same time
and then either they're all going to be
successful together or everybody's gonna
fail big time for a are for example we
don't have that ecosystem yet so i think
i think magically for example is a
company that's very forward-looking and
they're probably like five years out
to actually building something that we
can see but it'll take a while for that
to happen but thinking about the entire
ecosystem for any technology is
absolutely critical and yeah that
includes the content creation in your
slides you had this grid of other
different viewpoints um do you like the
human eye has like these different
acuity regions like they can see more
detail in at the center yeah do you
somehow exploit that fact to and maybe
can we talk about case contingent who
Vienna displays things like this right
where you want to have high resolution
wherever you're looking at and lower
resolution everywhere else that's
definitely very interesting especially
when you think about streaming
compression coding of large-scale visual
data I mean I would say burn zeros group
they do lot of work in that space but
we're mostly interested in the devices
user experiences
alright alright then we can figure our
speaker one more time
you